[Music]
the top domestic violent extremist
threat comes from racially or ethnically
motivated violent extremists
specifically those who advocated for the
superiority of the white race we face an
elevated threat from domestic violent
extremists i've decided to establish a
domestic terrorism unit
to augment our existing approach
well that big announcement they really
needed to show some results of all that
domestic extremism right and according
to jim jordan well the results were not
honest the top republican on the house
judiciary committee told fox digital
that new whistleblower documents allege
that the fbi
is pressuring to reclassify cases as
domestic violent extremism that are not
examples of domestic violence extremism
and jordan alleges that this is being
done
in order to justify the biden
administration's push to focus on these
cases and have a special unit focusing
on them here now is glenn greenwald
pulitzer prize-winning independent
journalist whose work i read on sub
stack glenn
so they don't have enough of these
domestic violent extremism cases so i
guess they're going to find some
you know it's not surprising lori even
though they now cite january 6 is the
reason
they have to increase their attention to
this problem in fact even before january
6 the biden administration was saying
one of its key priorities was to import
the war on terror onto domestic soil and
make that be a new war on terror only
this time aimed at american citizens and
throughout 2021 there were so many
instances where dhs homeland security
issued one warning after the next
there's gonna be an attack on john on
the inauguration there's gonna be one
from kova there's gonna be one from the
tulsa massacre memorial none of which
materialize you could see them
exaggerating and inflating the threat
the entire time because what they want
to do is issue usher in all sorts of
authoritarian attacks on civil liberties
in the name of this domestic war on
terror and since they don't have the
cases now they're just making them up
which is by the way what they did during
the first war on terror as well
well i was mentioning this to matt
whitaker in the previous segment but
when you think of the concern that is
raised legitimately obviously that
vladimir putin
hounds and relentlessly persecutes his
political critics you start to see that
our justice department and what they're
doing and this is just one more example
of it
becomes what they
are waving their arms around about their
their they appear to be
hounding and prosecuting and surveilling
their political critics
you know we've obtained and i've done
reporting on the documents from homeland
security where they identify the kinds
of people they regard as quote unquote
domestic extremists and usually it's
just people with anti-establishment
politics they'll say people who
are against the government who question
the legitimacy of government authority
even there are sometimes people on the
left they'll say animal rights activists
or environmental activists and people on
the right who are pro-life activists
it's clearly aimed at any sort of
exercise of free speech and free
association and free political
protesting that the constitution's
supposed to guarantee that they're gonna
say are just extremists and now should
be regarded as terrorism
and glenn there's a feeling uh
among
many political observers that the
democrats squealing
over democracy is on the edge knife's
edge well that none of that is actually
genuine giving the fact that they're
propping up
all these supposed far-right candidates
now the dcc chair was asked about this
watch
when it comes to
the far right candidates are you
actively doing anything to help
candidates that you think might be
easier to beat
in november if you're talking about
trying to pick your opponent um you
might see us do that sure um and and and
i think sometimes it does make sense uh
and largely what you're doing is telling
voters a fact that if they're aware of
um it's important to them i think you
might see us do that sure
glenn so is democracy at risk
or not
which is it yeah you know you would
think or if the democrats really believe
what they're saying which is that
trump-aligned candidates are nazi white
supremacists bent on ending democracy
and installing a white nationalist
dictatorship they probably wouldn't be
supporting those candidates and it's so
funny to watch members of the january 6
committee like liz cheney and adam
kinzinger outraged because they actually
apparently believe the democrats and
they're saying wait we thought you
really believed that these candidates
were threats to democracy why are you
supporting them against anti-trump
republicans like peter major one of ten
republicans to vote for trump's
impeachment they apparently took the
democrats seriously and now are
realizing the whole thing was a scam
whoops glenn thank you great to see you
tonight hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else